I want to take a few minutes today to
talk about some conspiracy theories that
are very anti-semitic which have been
spreading in some right-wing circles and
unfortunately even in some left-wing
circles which in short are about blaming
supposed Israeli billionaires and the
words suppose it is important and you'll
know why in a second the theories are
that Israeli billionaires are really the
people interfering in American elections
the gist is it's not Russians that are
interfering it's not anybody else the
people really interfering are so-called
Israeli billionaires which of course is
code for the Jews now understand that
these are bad faith actors with a very
thinly veiled anti-semitic agenda but to
create these Jewish conspiracies about
using money to control things these
these are old anti-semitic tropes about
Jews we've been following on that those
tropes on this show for a decade but
let's look at how this all is coming
together the most important thing to
understand is that there are almost no
Israeli billionaires okay and even lots
of the people that are sometimes called
Israeli billionaires really sort of
aren't Israeli in any realistic sense so
if you want to figure out whether a
conspiracy theory has any merit you have
to as I said earlier this week
critically analyze primary sources so
the first thing to figure out is who are
all of the Israeli billionaires let's
figure that out first and a symbol
google search turns up a list of 23
people not 230 not 2,300 not 22,000
there are 23 people listed as Israeli
billionaires at least nominally as of
2018 we are talking here about a list
that is at the most 23 people but I
encourage you to go beyond just the list
look closely at this list and you will
realize a lot of these people aren't
even really Israeli in any sense other
than holding citizenship which is
available to any Jewish person who wants
it I was born in Argentina
I came to the US at age five I could go
and spend a year in Israel I think it
takes about a year and I can get Israeli
citizenship and then I could move right
back to the US would I be Israeli in
terms of the defining characteristic of
am I now in Israeli television host no
I'm not
so there are nominally 23 Israeli
billionaires but over the 23 you look at
a lot of them and they're not really
Israeli right robe Roman Abramovich from
Lithuania lives in the UK from Lithuania
lives in the UK okay he has Israeli
citizenship but not really what you
think of when you think of it an Israeli
billionaire and either born there nor
lives there hey y'all offer certainly
born in Israel has been living in Monaco
for a long time Patrick Draghi Moroccan
family moved to France lives in
Switzerland he has Israeli citizenship
it's not really an Israeli billionaire
in any relevant sense heed on offer
Romanian born lived in Israel for a
little while made his money in Asia and
the United States not even sure where he
lives now could be the US could be
London that really an Israeli
billionaire in the sense that the
conspiracy theorists want us to believe
one more example
hi I'm Saban born in Egypt went to
Israel has been living in Beverly Hills
for a very very long time is that really
what we're talking about when we say
Israeli billionaire so my point is even
on the merits you start with a list of
23 suppose at Israeli billionaires you
very quickly see that roughly half or
more don't even really fit the
definition and then very rapidly the
conspiracy theory on which this is all
built falls apart now there's one other
angle to this that I want to mention
some of these supposedly Israeli
billionaires as I told you live in the
United States they're really American in
practical terms
some of them might get involved in
politics as everyone has a right to do
who is an American citizen so once
you're talking about well when you say
Israeli billionaires are you talking
about just Americans Americans who live
in the United States and have American
citizenship they are getting involved in
politics that's part of the
than we have it's a broken system right
the system we have for how politics is
financed is disgustingly corrupt it's
completely broken but to single out
individuals who held or hold Israeli
citizenship but who really are Americans
as the real conspiracy is a very thinly
veiled anti-semitic trope and we
shouldn't fall for it when anyone else
gets involved in politics in the country
where they live it's called
participating in the election when a
handful of rich Jews do it it's Israeli
billionaires conspiring to influence
elections it's pathetic it's transparent
but sadly it works on a lot of people
and it's being used as the shiny thing
to take your attention away from real
election interference real voter
suppression real purges of the voter
rolls and all of the other things that
we've been talking about on this program
for the last three years and one month
of Donald Trump's presidency don't fall
for it don't fall for it let me know
what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman make sure you're following me
follow the show on Twitter at David
Pakman show we have a hell of a Friday
show for you today
do you feel like you just don't have
enough time to become as intellectually
well-rounded as you would like to be
that there are just not enough hours in
your week for you to read all of the
books that you want to read one of our
sponsors is called blinka stand it's an
app that lets you consume an entire
non-fiction book in 15 minutes it's only
about eight bucks a month but you can
try it for free for a week and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to
blankest comm slash Pakman what blinka
studs is take thousands of popular
nonfiction books and condense them into
either text or audio that you can read
or listen to in just 15 minutes and what
you get is all of the most important
ideas and information from the book
imagine being able to listen to an
entire nonfiction book in the amount of
time it takes you to drive or walk home
from work I just finished listening to
the way we eat now by bee Wilson whose
work I've recommended to you before
super interesting look at how the global
food system
works and impacts the way that we live
blink is has totally transformed how I
consume information I love it of course
I read a book in its entirety when I can
but there are simply just so many books
that I want to read and would not have
the time for if it weren't for blink
Asst
they have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent
then blink astiz for you